all right so welcome to the secret life
of puns today we're going to talk about
a really important theme double pawns
[Music]
but today I wanted to focus on the good
side of double pawns and I prepared a
bunch of games where a player gets
doubled pawns relatively early and
because of it gets some advantage or get
some very interesting dynamic play and
and goes on to win so the first game I
want to show is from an opening that
maybe some of you play I see it a lot in
scholastic chess
it's the four Knights opening anyone
play this for the white side or for the
black side yeah it's it can be shocking
when high-level players play this
because you think of it as a kids
opening but it's a very playable opening
and it's an opening I encounter a lot as
black and sometimes it's hard to get in
vantage cuz it's so symmetrical and
symmetrical positions will normally
favorite white question Caruana
I'm sure a lot of like strong players
have had this position at some points
yeah yeah he's playing petrov which
could it could transpose into four
knights but the main line here for white
is Bishop e5 and usually the best
approach for black is just to copy white
play Bishop before and this is a main
line a black light will castle black
ball Castle d3 and G six so far complete
copy catch s and then white usually
plays Bishop to g5 and this is the first
moment I want to talk about because
there's a move here this is actually
part of my opening preparation where if
I'm black and I'm playing against
perhaps a lower rated player I don't
want to copy white further I would like
to create some imbalance and and break
the symmetry so perhaps you guys can
think here and come up with a an option
for black yes Ashish
Bishop takes c3 is one option
any other ideas a six so I'll just
highlight the options with the arrows
any other ideas yeah 94 it's a move
anything else
yep Bishop to e6 very logical
any other suggestions yeah h6 very
logical anything else all these moves
have some purpose
no one has adjusted the the move that I
like to play here and the move I like to
play looks a bit suspicious at first
yeah you have an idea
d5 would be a plunder cousin I take d5
there's some pin action so let me show
you the move I play yeah 97 and maybe
you could figure this out knowing the
theme where I'm willing to accept double
pawns I'm inviting white to take on f6
and seemingly damage the King side pawn
structure now this game i didn't mention
it's between victor miss nikolewski is
playing black and playing whites is
Andre Jove's arvid's I've never heard of
before raided a 2275 Michalowski is a
relatively strong GM now white in this
position takes on f6 up for the
challenge G take f6 and now we reach a
much more in balanced position a few
moves ago is perfectly symmetrical now
it's it's quite imbalanced and I want to
ask here
what has improved in blacks position
whether it what's a good thing about
these double pawns yeah yeah open G file
which could be a good thing it could be
a bad thing because the King is perhaps
a bit more exposed but in some cases if
King h8 rook G this played black can use
this file for an attack anything else
yeah in many cases wack would like to
play a 5 in some cases bless you
black would like to play f5 take and if
take can play f5 again bless you again
so there are there are some interesting
factors with the double f funds here now
what we're gonna see is a something a
bit different than the ideas I've shown
another another idea for black I want to
show in this position is because Anaya
is on e7 c6 would be possible and
perhaps d5 so just got a nice Center
also possible our ideas of knight g6 and
Knight f4 so the position is rich with
ideas a lot of like nice attacking ideas
and position ideas to just further
improve the position for black so white
plays 9 h4 here maybe trying to
discourage pawn f5 also allowing the
Queen to potentially come in to h5 black
plays c6 Bishop a4 and now knight g6 and
now after Knight takes c6 pawn to g6 the
G file is closed but the H file is
opened and we can see in this position
okay each side has eight pawns but black
is the only one with a half-open file
question ah that's a good point if he
takes with f-fun he would get rid of the
double pawns but he wants to keep the
double pawns for two reasons first of
all it's better center with more pawns
closer to the center and secondly half
of in each file and we'll see how it
plays out later in the game so Bishop to
b3 was played black is already doing
pretty very happy just because two
bishops and good Center but I want I
want to focus in this position because
there's an important move that blacks
should play next move that kind of
facilitates a nice a nice series of
moves
yes yeah King g7 the a trial is open but
box not exploiting it yet in order to
exploit it you need you want your rook
on h8 so King g7 is a really nice and
simple improving move planning rocket
shapes and very soon we're gonna see
that black gets a really nice attack on
the Kings side with the the half-open
file so f4 is played now it's
interesting because white is also trying
to attack on the King side and it's
perhaps a battle of who can attack more
effectively ro kha that's played take
take and Queen f3 so it looks like black
is under some pressure and here we see
perhaps a drawback of having the double
pawns this pawn is not defended the
Queen is tied down and white has to be
on a constant watch of f6 but in this
position black plays a5 which is maybe a
peculiar move I think he's just trying
to gain space perhaps considering ideas
of b5 a4 and putting the ball in White's
courts so white plays a four in response
Bishop c5 King h1 and now I think it's
this position I would like you guys to
think and try and find possible
continuation for black and what I didn't
mention this was a rapid game and
sometimes in rapid chess you want to
strive for positions where you're the
one having the initiative and you're the
one making the threats so keep that in
mind in this sort of position yeah
aha
does anyone else want to sacrifice the
rook like this was anyone else thinking
ripped a gauge - one - a couple people
a few more people that's certainly one
idea and I'll go ahead and say rook take
a chew is played in the game from a from
a practical standpoint I think this is a
very good move because it's rapid
there's less time for white to think
meaning there's less time for white to
accurately defend if this were a longer
game this might be risky because there's
no immediate win as we'll see after
Queen h8 and black is going for perhaps
long-term compensation to try and keep
the White King exposed I should point
out a perhaps better move here is rook
h4 or at least more sound move where
you're not sacrificing you're simply
wanting to increase the pressure ideas
of Bishop g4 or even Rick at four which
would perhaps be a bit more controlled
in terms of attacking but rook take h2
certainly leads to a more entertaining
position and we're gonna see black goes
down the rook but gets a media play
against the king and now the king is
dragged up the board because it can't
retreat to g1 as a bishop is controlling
the square so the King has to move up to
g3 and then black plays at five and now
we can see the king is in big trouble
the King can't retreat in either
direction and f4 is coming and if f4 it
comes the Queen would need to sacrifice
itself so this is probably what Nicholas
T calculated when he played rook take h2
as he saw until f5 and he probably
realized that there's there's a good
amount of compensation for the rook but
white was able to defend here Y plays a
nice move d4 obstructing the bishop from
controlling f2 and after f4 king f2
Queen h4
I think it was in this position white
played a natural move King e2 if you
turn on that engine here the engine hate
skinny too and it loves g3 which is a
very much a computer move g3 looks quite
risky but it would have given light a
decisive advantage assuming like would
continue correctly but will focus on
what happened in the game because after
a Keaney - what this allows is Bishop to
g4 which I don't think Michalowski
played nicoleff ski took on on d4 with
the bishop if he were to play Bishop to
g4 white would be getting a decent
amount of material for the Queen keep in
mind white is already up a rook and I
could just get the two bishops and
blacks attack would kind of fizzle out
and light would be having a rook a
knight and a bishop for I believe a
queen and a pawn so I like the decision
by black to not grab the Queen but to
continue the initiative and to keep the
bishops on the board question C take see
take D for wait I don't understand see C
file as this file Oh II take T for you
take T for it might be possible in this
position but it could walk into Queen
take F 4 and F sevens of targets so I
think bishop take d 4 was played just to
to keep the F file closed
and then Bishop g4 still a threat and
the the bishop the dark square bishop is
defended
so why plays up for white plays g3 here
and then after Queen h2 the King the
king has a couple options I want to take
a poll here a couple options are King a
one or King D three and some of this can
be calculated some of this might you
might have to rely on intuition sorry
Oh King d1 is also possible King d1
might be risky though as the King is
staying on the same diagonal as a queen
but we can include King d1 in the poll
okay maybe I've discouraged you guys to
pick King d1 though so who would vote
for for King g3 in this position two
people four people six people okay who
would vote for kingi one less people
okay about three anyone vote for a king
do you want
no okay the move that was played is
actually very surprising king d3 was
played
I thought King e1 should be played but
king d3 just seems to be a bit awkward
as a king is just stuck in the center
I think Kingi one was a much safer
option and now we're gonna see how how
lot capitalizes on this a nice move
Bishop e3 and the key here is that black
just wants to get the rook to b8 and
it's a hard plan to stop white played 92
and now Bishop h3 attacking the rook on
f1 but more importantly threatening
erupted Yates and very soon the the
white king is going to be in the meeting
that rook each one was played question
inside the bishop h3
rook ad one it would probably be a bit
similar like Bishop h3r okay ch1 it's me
very similar bear with me
let's focus on the game line because
we're gonna see a very similar idea
because the Queen appears to be trapped
here early so Queen looks like has to go
to g2 or f2 and black doesn't
necessarily want to trade Queens but
here black can focus on targeting the
White King and here the move would be
rep d8 the King has to move King c3 and
amazingly enough in this position black
has forced mate even though the Queen's
out of play
black has enough resources to to win
this position so for those of you
watching at home if you want to pause
the video and try and calculate may them
to and till until the end feel free to
do so but for the live audience you're
welcome to throw out suggestions yes
Bishop d2 the most forcing move I will
say this is the best first move we're
forcing King c4 yes I play Bishop e6
check King c5 my king is going to
continue walking up the board
you could play Bishop before king b6 but
you're not going to made in two more
moves so Bishop d2 is the correct first
move black should not play Bishop e6
here there's a stronger move I think I
heard it b6 yeah b6 is is not an easy
move to find it's a quiet move a quiet
prophylactic move and it's especially
not an easy move to find when I tell you
it was forced mate simply because when
you think force mate you think Chuck
check check and then mate here it's
check quiet move and then then we'll see
what happens but b6 is very important
because we take away the c5 square which
is a1 escape square for the King and now
all the squares around the King are
controlled and we're threatening made in
one with Bishop e6 Bishop e6 is very
hard to stop I'm not mistaken there's
only one way to stop it which is g4 and
now if you see the next move don't
scream it out but black to move here
Nathan - and again feel free to pause
the video at home yeah Adi on passant is
not legal the pond was on g3 good try
though if the pawn came from g2 on
passant would be legal but yeah
illy will move in Russia you got
arrested for that yes
Queen sacrifice I think maybe some
people were fixated on getting the
Bishop to e6
but there's another idea of getting the
rook to d4 so queen take you to really
nice Queen sacrifice Queen take you to
rook T for checkmate
okay well take questions um yeah
question
Oh Bishop g5 here probably yeah we could
have fun calculating this this looks
really fun pawn take you take the Queen
I take here now we have two sets of
double pawns it's double check if you
play King c3 I'll take on a3 that should
be winning for for black it's not
immediate mates but let's okay let's
continue calculating Kim take e4 if I'm
not mistaken black has made than - wait
a minute
pretty sure it's made into yeah
I was a lot of news yeah Bishop at 5:00
King Tiki five as been Feingold always
says always playoff six yeah
and just a beautiful mates I didn't
actually prepare this exact line before
the game but this is really nice the
bishop here okay the double pawns not
maybe not too relevant but the piece
coordination pretty amazing for luck so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this game 97
was like if you if you're playing black
and you're not sure what to play against
this very symmetrical for Knights I
recommend learning this line with 97
going back to this position I think it's
it's a really nice line to play once you
understand the idea is it double pawns
are actually not so bad for black in
that case I'm going to take a look at
another game the next game is also going
to be in a similar type of opening in
the Italian opening or in the gioco
piano I think very similar
does anyone play like Italian gioco
piano for white or for black how many
people play it for whites a couple
people how many play against it is black
yeah you do okay and you do nice cool so
Italian for those of you don't know this
one starts a bit strangely it starts as
a bishops opening but it transposes
pretty quickly after white plays c3 and
ken west we were looking at this before
which we were talking about all these
trans positions this is another strange
transposition this is kind of a classic
Italian variation I should mention
playing black is super Grandmaster
Michael Adams who is one of my favorite
players to get inspiration from because
he just has such a simple style like
when you watch his games like he just
puts his pieces on like all he's very
natural very strong squares and this
game he's playing against Kevin spagett
who's another a strong GM but not a
super GM mid 25 hundredths so in this
game Adam plays some high-level opening
idea he starts with a six which maybe
looks a bit and use
because it's not castling it's not going
for development but he simply wants to
tuck the bishop away on a seven where it
can't be attacked with tempo and the
bishop on a seven usually stays there
for much of the game where it exerts a
lot of pressure along this this diagonal
so he plays Bishop a7 immediately I
should also mention another idea one of
the reasons why white played the ship to
be three if the bishop er is still on
c-4 black would have ideas of
potentially playing g6 and then Knight
a5 to win the bishop pair so it's one
reason white plays an early Bishop to b3
but game continues castle d6 next
several moves are very normal 92 castle
and now now rook e1 so white is going
for the very typical Italian plan of
playing Knight f1 to g3 kind of slow
methodical chess but this is where Adams
Adams plays a nice and and very
aggressive move I think what I'll do
I'll show you guys a move and then we'll
try and understand it I think someone
already said the move Knight g4 which
sometimes this move can be very
effective in this case it doesn't appear
to be so effective on the surface
because white simply plays rookie 2 and
white now wants to play h3 and just kick
the night away so now the question
becomes how do you justify Knight g4
what's the follow up in this position
f5 would be illegal but if you if we
combine the moves you said King H a you
say f5 yes
King h8 it's the best move yeah f5 is
such a common pawn break in this sort of
structure and that's one of the main
reasons black goes for Knight g4 is to
execute this pawn break to open up that
file or the f2 pawn is still a long-term
targets
now light play is h3 now we're going to
combine it with your idea of dropping
the knight back not to f6 but to h6 now
96 is a difficult move to play sometimes
because first of all the nights just on
the rim it seems like it's just on such
a bad square but also after night f1 y
could potentially threaten to take it
and and double blacks pawns but what
have we learned about double pawns
they're not always so bad right so in
this position we just go for f5 we open
that file we're not scared of the double
pawns white went ahead and takes on h6
and now we see double pawns happen but
if we stop to evaluate the position
black has everything going for him this
is actually a really fun position to
play for black the King on h8 is very
safe there's really no attacking
resources for whites Black has open
diagonal for the bishop having some
x-ray vision against the white king that
file is bound to open after a witch like
if that file ever opens and I could be a
target on f3 as well and there might be
tactics with Bishop take h3
there's also ideas of bringing the Queen
in maybe the Queen could occupy the G
file
there's also ideas of maneuvering the
Knights and I could find some purpose
maybe coming to g6 an f4 so when I teach
students who play e5 is black against e4
I usually like to show this line because
it's it's just a great piece of opening
preparation and I think it's important
to understand the ideas here and at
least see this full game and see how
atoms actually execute a nice attack and
wins very quickly so we'll go forward
here and for the most part we'll just
kind of marvel at a DIN display I'll try
and give some insights but in this
position we can see there's already a
tactical threat of Bishop take h3
because this G pawn is a bit overworked
defending the pawn and the knight so
white plays Knight 1 h2 which is kind of
a sad move it's defending the knight but
now the Knights are kind of
overlapping each other not the best
harmony Adams plates Queen f6 very
natural Queen d2 and now rook 88 so just
really optimizing all the pieces and now
King h1 question ooh Queen g6 double
attacking d3 and h3 I think light can
respond with a double attack right
Knight H for the counter a double attack
and you don't really want to give away
the bishop pair so yeah I positions like
this you you don't want white to like
trade when it's not necessary you just
want to continue building up pressure so
the move here
it was rook 88 and now King h1 sorry
always focus on the center but actually
I think the funny thing with rook 88 is
the rook doesn't want to stay on yet
the rook wants to go to the G file so
only only half oven or no there's two
half open vials of G in that file so
black wants run one rook on that file
one work on the G file and black
couldn't play rook G and immediately
because the bishop was controlling g8 so
this maneuver of rook to e8 to e7 to g7
it was a really nice path and yeah Adams
had the patience and the time for it so
he's just optimizing even further a3
another sad move I don't know why he
played a three maybe he was just waiting
for his own destruction
yeah g4 just go completely insane maybe
that would be a way to destroy yourself
quicker
I think g4 g 4 attacks with bishop I
think maybe I could respond with Bishop
d7 and then I would black would have a
potential pawn break with h5 so we can
analyze g4 Bishop d7 you want to play
rook g1 maybe it's possible another
perhaps drawback is black could just be
patient
and focus on some outpost square and
then the bishop could come to c6 even
more harmony so it would be interesting
well whites already under like a lot of
pressure here yeah maybe he could have
done something more interesting than a
three if yeah if kramnik was playing
maybe he would still prefer whites but
okay let's let's go forward here rook g1
h5 and Athens is just so resourceful
using everything at his his power
maybe he played h5 to prevent g4 it's
possible just trying to be super
restrictive because now white is is very
much cramped Bishop a2 so that was the
idea of a three to put the bishop on you
two not sure what that accomplishes now
Adams plays Bishop d7 which is a nice
move and I think we can understand the
idea of this move based on the line we
just looked at where he wants to bring
the bishop to c6 and bring the Knights
to the King side
so after B 497 improving further now d4
is played so finally some strike by
white in the center Adams just ticks
ticks and Knight g6 and now we see the
Knights coming probably to f4 as Ben
Feingold would say knife f4 rookie for
life for h4 bishop c6 very natural like
not and then white plays d5 so now the
bishop is actually forced to move to
some different square I think Adams
included Bishop to c6 because he wanted
to provoke d5 as it opens up the
diagonal for the other bishop it also
closes down the diagonal for the bishop
on a2 and the lights for a bishop for
black actually finds a nice square on b5
where it seems like it's just staring
into empty space but we're gonna see the
purpose of this in just a few moves so
g3 was played
and now I'm pretty sure when Adams
played his next move he just saw the end
of the game he played Knight h3
attacking the rook just going into the
heart of of whites King side attacking
the rook also attacking that 7 pawn so
we see that the rook can't move to f1
now so the bishop guards f1 so it only
moved to the Fen both the rook and F
pawn is to play rook g2 and you see a
crazy move don't shatter that let other
people think black to move how to
continue in this position mmm I take F 2
you are attacking enough to punt twice
but you would need a follow up after a
rook take F 2 you would be giving a
light to minor pieces for the rook and
the pawn there's a stronger move ken
west Queen a1 Queen e1 is interesting
Queen a1 going for some back ring stuff
but there's rook e1 so there's a
stronger move yes
is it that fun who else wanted to say
Bishop a5 assume two more people three
more people the whole class now okay
yeah Bishop f1 very aesthetic move yeah
always play this [ __ ] f1 rights and
white just resigns here if we understand
what's going on the rook is essentially
trapped Knight take f1 is possible but
then there's Queen takeoff 3 pinning
attacking threatening Knight take f2
because now the rook isn't defending f2
so it's a pretty brutal game
I can't tell you how many players would
be so concerned about having double H
bonds rather than beef being focused on
peace activity so a theme in this
lecture is not necessarily that double
pawns are good but it's sometimes that
peace activity is way more important
than pawn structure that's an idea that
I think everyone should internalize
especially lower level players sometimes
really focus on pawn structure because
it's so easy to identify but if you can
activate your pieces it's much more
powerful factor in the position any
questions about this game should move on
maybe see one more game we got some time
left I prepared a lot of games I can
show you a game that I played I play
that I've been travelling around the
world for the last year and I've played
chess in four different continents last
December I went to Australia for a month
and then I went to Southeast Asia then I
was in Europe just last week so I've
been playing really all around the world
and the game I want to show you from
from one of my trips was played in
Australia I played in Invitational
tournaments in Melbourne and I was only
player there from the US and I was
playing older gentleman
but decently strong player rated just
over 2,100 and I used I use the same
theme that we've been talking about as
we'll see so let me put this in training
mode and we're gonna zoom through the
opening I don't think the openings to
relevance
I played the English opening and I
actually played what turned into a
reverse Sicilian I played a three here
and then he played d5 so this is
essentially a reverse open Sicilian and
after Queen sisa or Queens to c2 for
black it would be Queen c7 this is a
reverse time mama variation which I play
for the black side so essentially I have
one of my favorite openings for black
but I'm I have an extra tempo
so the game continued they both kind of
just developed we trade that on c3
maybe I should point out I took away
from the center in this position I think
a lot of people are told take towards
the center with your pawns if you have
the chance I take away from the center
for two reasons first of all I want to
develop my bishop more quickly and I
want the open D file for a rook I want
to be able to play rook do you want and
perhaps annoy his Queen so the game
continues I focus on King side
development
yeah I focused on all development and
then I Castle and then he played this
move Bishop to g4 maybe he had Bishop h3
if he were to play Bishop h3 I would
play 91 and just defend everything but
he played Bishop to g4 and he has a very
clear threat of capturing the Knights so
the question for you guys what to do in
as white in this position yes
Bishop e2 that's possible move so you
would be planning to meet Bishop take f3
with Bishop to Guthrie and it would just
be a trade fair enough any other
suggestions kind west h1 mm-hmm anyone
else agree king h1 yeah King h1 is the
move I play and King h1 is a very very
important move which allowed my my
attack to formulate and yeah allowing
double ponts and I baited him him him
into taking the Knights probably he
shouldn't have taken but if he doesn't
want to take then the bishop doesn't
have much purpose on g4 I might even try
and provoke him by playing h3 next move
so he did take and after I take we can
see my King is already optimized the
King is very safe on h1 and now I want
to play ripped g1 and in this case ok
the double pawns maybe not so impressive
alone but the whole facts or the whole
whole purpose of having them is to
access aji file
and the play from this moment until most
of the most rest of the game was it was
pretty simple for whites but we'll keep
going here queen h5 attacking that pawn
I do have to defend and sometimes when
you know you're gonna get double pawns
you just want to make sure you have
enough ways to defend them if they are
weak in this case he can only attack
that pawn once he can't really attack it
another time so you play Queen h4 here
rook g1 now he played ninety eight which
is an interesting move as plan is to
play 96 potentially control or defend g7
and maybe even get the Knight to f4 but
I was happy to play rook g4 with tempo
and just double up on the G file now I'm
very ready to take on g7 so he defended
96 now there's a few factors in this
position that during the game I was
trying to find a way to take advantage
of of course I want to somehow have
tactics against the g7 pawn I also
wanted to to try and target the Queen on
h3 because the Queen is almost trapped
in some cases so I'm gonna give you guys
a first move I played here and then I'll
have you find the next move in the
calculation play a very forcing move
rook 1 g3 attacking the Queen only one
safe Square for the Queen and now
White's a move in this position how to
proceed
yes you said Bishop Bishop f1 who
following the wisdom of time flying gold
why Bishop f1 oh you want to trap the
Queen you would like to play this that's
an interesting idea I don't know if I
considered that during the game f6 yeah
black can respond with f6 going against
the wisdom of n.flying gold and allowing
the retreat of the Queen and there's a
more powerful move here rather than
Bishop f1 a lot more aggressive yeah in
the back mm-hmm why f4 yeah we want the
bishop to stay on e to to have
discoveries against the Queen and
actually when I play that for it was
part of a long calculation I probably
thought ahead he's five to six moves
which I can try and demonstrate here if
you guys want to follow along oops
so let's imagine f4 and then lock them
take on f4 and then it looks like I can
win the Queen right rook take g7 then
they take g7 but there's a lot of things
hanging right I think what I'll do I'll
just go ahead and show you what happened
the game I do play out for he does take
and I do take and now the the point is
that I can after Knight take g7 my rook
is attacked by the pawn but I can first
take on g7 rather than take the Queen
right away cuz it come up with Jack so
take on g7 take and now Bishop d4 check
so I save the save the bishop before I
take the Queen now the interesting thing
is he can move his king up the board to
defend his queen and win the bishop
which is what he does
but it looks very very risky for his
king what he was trying to do is hold on
to the material and in this situation he
has two rooks for a queen
and normally that's okay for the black
side but with the King on h5 the most
developed piece it's going to run into
problems and now it's all about
exploiting the king do you want to
suggest a move Bishop g7 is a candidate
move Bishop g7 is interesting
maybe rook rook f d8 or up g8 even Queen
d1 check and then King maybe even King
itch for it could get really weird
you said Pawnee 5 in this position yeah
25 is certainly a candidate move to
unleash the Queen and attack the pawn
I think Pawnee 5 can be met with King h6
and okay white still has a good position
but it was a matter of finding the maybe
the most forcing continuation I went for
a queen d1 here where it's just probably
the most forcing move I was part of a
calculation after a king g5 I have Queen
g1 check the King can't really run back
if it moves back to h6 I owed Bishop g7
to win material so yeah it has to go
back to h5 and then I go into g7 I was
just a sequence of activating the Queen
while keeping the initiative now I want
to take on h7 so he plays h6 and now I
am three threatening Queen g4 mates so
every move I've played basically since
f4 has been a forcing move now he if he
plays rook g8 here he would lose f7
right so he tried the different move
Bishop to g5 and that was just a matter
of tactics
I could try maybe somehow h4 was
certainly a candidate moved
try and bring up the King further down
the board but I saw a simple tactic here
at Bishop c5 simply removing the rook
from defending f7 so just pawn grab the
rook defends and I'm keeping the
initiative again I attacked the rook I
win the pawn now I'm threatening mate in
one
he plays rook c6 I play Bishop to e7
because the bishops pinned I'm
threatening h4 King tickets for their
would be made on g4 so black is is
completely collapsing here few more
moves were played rook b6 h for rook
take B to H take g5 and he resigned here
I did want to show though if if he plays
on and he plays rook to g8 White's a
move may than one and this is for maybe
the younger plays yes g6 g6 is a nice
mate because it said this it opens up
the Queen and opens up the bishop and
then as a pawn checkmate - so again this
was just another nice example of having
the double pawns allowing the G file to
open and then using the G file for a
very nice attack okay before we start
this game has anyone heard of the player
Albert capping it anyone maybe kind of
he's someone that I've met many times
before he's actually a relative of he's
actually the grandfather of one of my my
best friends and he's a former coach of
many very strong GM's some World
Championship challengers and there's
also a variation named after him in the
benoni
called a cap and good variation and he's
someone that I learned from growing up
because he would come to Chicago almost
every year and teach us chess camp and
every year at the chess camp he would
show the same game because every year
all the
kids would forget the game and he would
just show it again in hearing again and
again and the game is essentially a
really nice bit of opening preparation
against the Sicilian defense and it's a
game I forgot about until until watching
one of the previous st. Louis Chess Club
lectures actually the one that was
uploaded today with Robert Lewandowski I
don't know if any of you guys attended
it was a game where one of his opponents
made some positional mistake of allowing
Knight take that was you
that was you okay where you allow Knight
take e3 and you've got double pawns
right so this in this game I'm going to
show you when it can be good where
Knight take e3 can can actually lead to
good things for whites so without
further ado let's get to the the game
this game is a classical Sicilian cap
and good is playing white group recheck
who is uh I think a relatively strong GM
is playing black if I'm not mistaken
there's a variation names the Cupra
trick defense in the Sicilian
but this Sicilian was what we call the
the classical Sicilian with knight c6 d6
Knight f6 Knight c6 and d6 and I guess
against the classical Sicilian White has
a variety of different options in this
case captain gutt likes to play this the
side line Bishop to e3 normally Bishop
e3 would be considered a mistake because
it allows Knight g4 but he was very well
prepared he's studied this position very
deeply and he understood that he can
afford to not only give away the bishop
pair but damage his pawn structure to
get piece activity so you got initiative
and to build up an early attack and
focus on development so that's what he
does he plays Bishop b5 he allows my
take III what was played F take e3 and
white now does have the double pawns
very ugly double isolated pawns black
has a bishop pair but White has
initiative and White has open F file and
black is very much underdeveloped has
only developed pieces pinned
and attacked twice so there's a lot of
good things for white about this
position so the game continues Bishop d7
and like castles so White's essentially
completed development before black is
anywhere close to castling a six is
played and of course white wants to make
threats as quickly as possible so Bishop
takes c6 takes c6 and Queen f3 nice move
threatening simply threatening made in
one and black doesn't have too many ways
to defend this is actually a good
exercise because there are perhaps a
couple candidate moves here for a black
I want to get some some options from the
crowd what would you guys play in this
position as black yes at six is an
option and what else yes Queen e7 is
that a hand raised no any other moves so
f6 were queenie seven
so yeah you just mentioned the strongest
move the strongest move is not Queenie
seven it's not a six it's to actually
sacrifice a pawn and play Queen f6 and
even very strong players won't find this
move the idea would be after the the
Queen's got traded black can focus on
positional play and black has some
positional compensation in this position
Queen f6 was not played most natural
move Queenie sab in this plate I will
say f6 is perhaps a bit too weakening so
Queen e7 it seems like black has things
on your control but we're gonna see
white light continually makes threats
and there's a really nice move here pony
five simply trying to open up the
position while black is a bit stuck in
the center and the idea is that if pawn
take E 5 white is is crushing with
Knight takes c6 we're now the Queen's
attacked it spawns attacked a7 pawn
still a target that rook is a target on
eight and this is not going to end well
for black maybe Queen f6 would be
possible but then I assume they take E 5
with a discovered attack and white will
be up upon with a good position so so
black play is perhaps the most natural
move pawn to d5 trying to keep the
center closed and now white players are
really resourceful move and I'm pretty
sure this is still part of captain goats
opening preparation do you want to
suggest it you said II for a different
pawn move b4 which kind of comes out of
nowhere but the idea is to try and
destabilize blacks really solid plan
structure by playing b5 and we're gonna
see how effective this is after g6 b5
targeting the pawn on c6 black House
respond the most natural move is c5 and
again white play is a very unexpected
move here I would actually be impressed
if anyone can find White's next move I
already see a hand raised
yeah what and I take d5 don't go too
insane it was not a night 85 but it's
probably just as insane doesn't I take
t5 yes okay that's way too insane you
need a purpose if you're gonna sacrifice
a night you need a you need some kind of
follow-up in the position and because
we're low in time I think I'll go ahead
and show you guys knight c6 Knight c6 is
actually a normal move I keep the night
it's not a sacrifice the move played was
efore leveraging another pawn break
trying to open up the center further and
the tactics work out really nicely for a
white where the knight is hanging on d4
but if black were to take why can take
on d5 the other night is hanging but if
black takes this Knight
it doesn't end well after d6 in this
position the Queen attacks rook and the
Queen also pressures f7 and the black
queen really has just knows grace you
have a question no I just pawn take d5
was good enough yeah so e4 blocks under
a serious serious pressure doesn't want
to take the knight on d4 he plays Bishop
g7 just trying to castle as quickly as
possible but now we're gonna see white
gets a nice advantage simply after
taking on d5 still leaves a knight
hanging a knight still can't be captured
due to the same reasons d6 would happen
and black would be falling apart here
so black does Castle and now now there's
a few tempting moves for white looks
like d6 is very attractive capping good
plays a nice move knight c6 simply a
nice outpost in blacks territory and
after Bishop takes c6 pawn takes c6
this is really nice structure now the
double pawns have vanished but these
pawns are very very strong
Sheila Pollan c6.r very well defended
passed pawn in blacks territory so now
we'll go relatively quickly because
white does have sense
a very nice advantage and we'll see how
white converts the position to rook b8
a4 a6 this was actually an exercise if
we had more time I would slow down in
here
if you want to pause the video at home
and find the best move for white you can
do so the best move is Knight to e4 with
the idea of simply taking on c5 and what
happened the game after take on b5 and
Knight takes e5 if you just see where
the night is going you'll see a lot of
works 9 a 6 is a threat and 97 would be
a triple of work threat so there's no
way black and stop all the forks white
is win the material white went up to
exchange and then then it was just a
matter of converting rook take you six
really really nice move leveraging the
pin Queen a7 and we'll keep going here
c4 again we see double pawns and we see
the use of the C pawn after just a few
more moves
White is actually threatening this take
and then rook d7 and that's essentially
what happened
and rook take f7 a very nice uh just
simplifying move i should mention if
tick tick tick tick they're a b c seven
and white would be winning so the game
ended after taking on a seven rook c8
white to move
oh no queen c3 was played Queen takes e5
and Queen g7 Azure threats
now after a bishop f8 this is where rook
take out they displayed and then the
pawns unstoppable or it could be stopped
but then there's a skewer and and
there's no there's no background for
black so I think I'll I'll end it there
hopefully you guys can take away some
inspiration and remember that piece
activity more important than double
plants
[Music]